good afternoon my name is Claude Steele
I'm the Provost of Columbia University
and it is my great pleasure to welcome
all of you to a world leaders forum
event this one is co-sponsored with the
columbia university committee on global
thought and i want to thank the
committee and its distinguished chair
university professor joseph stiglitz
will be up here in a second for their
ongoing contributions to this forum
today we will be hearing an address
titled the new economic order and the
millennium development goals from the
prime minister of Spain Jose Luis
rodríguez Zapatero we are joined as well
by members of a broader spanish
delegation including mr. miguel martinez
Minister of Foreign Affairs and
cooperation mrs. Bibiano ie do minister
of equality and mr. hey-zeus caldera
executive vice president of the ideas
foundation I want to welcome to Columbia
University each of you and all of the
other distinguished guests from the spec
of the Spanish delegation Columbia
University President Lee Bollinger
launched the world leaders forum in 2003
as a university-wide initiative to
support uninhibited dialogue on the most
pressing economic political
environmental and social questions of
our time questions that with each
passing year have larger and larger
global dimensions over the past seven
years the forum has offered an
opportunity for more than 15,000
students faculty and staff to directly
engage important figures from 48 nations
representing all corners of the globe
our experience has confirmed the
animating principle of the world leaders
forum that only through informed
dialogue critical scholarship
a free exchange of ideas will answers
emerge to the biggest problems facing
the world today the role of universities
in creating a space of uninhibited and
critical discussion of controversial
issues has been noted on many occasions
if anything the changes we are seeing in
public discourse served to heighten the
importance of this role this role of
universities universities not only are
places where difficult conversations are
respected and encouraged today it
sometimes appears that universities may
be the only remaining venues where such
conversations occur with any regularity
in the world leaders forum being held at
Columbia this week our university
community once again is hearing from a
broad and dynamic group of political
leaders the diversity of viewpoints
through the forum presented through the
forum is a principal measure of its
success while providing a university
forum does not imply an endorsement of
the views expressed in these addresses
or the policies pursued by these
governments we have a responsibility as
a global center of learning to offer our
community the chance to engage in
conversations with men and women
directly involved in leading in meeting
the major challenges of the 21st century
it is my pleasure at this point to turn
the program over to Professor Jeffrey
Sachs director of Columbia's Earth
Institute from 2002 to 2006 professor
Sachs directed the United Nations
Millennium Project and advised un
secretary-general kofi annan on the
Millennium Development Goals he
currently serves as special adviser to
un secretary-general ban ki-moon with no
further ado Jeffrey
Prime Minister I can't tell you how much
fun it is to have you in our home and
how grateful we are to you to your
ministers ambassadors and distinguished
delegation for joining us at Columbia
University we're really profoundly
honored that you've come here today
yesterday you spoke magnificently and
very compellingly from the rostrum of
the General Assembly about the moral
commitment and the practical urgency of
achieving the Millennium Development
Goals and this continues your tradition
of tremendous global leadership on these
issues so it's a privilege for me to be
able to say thank you to you in this way
and to commend you for taking an issue
which is crucial for the world but often
overlooked in a very noisy environment
and especially at the time of economic
crisis and so much strife and so much
distraction and you've kept this agenda
clear in mind for the people of Spain
and also for the people of the world
it's been a privilege and i know it will
continue to be a privilege and honor and
a matter of great great excitement to
continue to work with you on these
themes secretary-general ban ki-moon I
asked Prime Minister South Petero to
co-chair a major group called the mdg
advocates which will be a group during
the next five years to continue to
promote the millennium development goals
in a variety of ways from the point of
view of the business sector the
philanthropic sector and global public
opinion and we met at montclair at the
president's of residency in an office of
this group just in July to begin this
thrilling process we're also thrilled
that we have the
the launch in the United States as it
were of another wonderful path-breaking
report of a foundation that you
established and we have the executive
vice president kazoos caldera with us a
great leader in these issues former
minister of labour and a leading figure
on all aspects of social development and
progressive thinking this EAS foundation
fund hace only dais is a wonderful and
and i would say incredibly fruitful
venue for thinking broadly and boldly
about key issues and Joe Stiglitz headed
the committee from our side as advisors
to the foundation in this report and I
was thrilled to do similar job with the
foundation a couple of years ago on the
challenge of peasant agriculture as a
way to proceed into solving the problems
of hunger in the world and I just want
to predict the same thing with this
report is what happened with the
previous one which is that Spain
championed the cause of mdg won the
fight against hunger took a bold stand
that something new had to be done and by
the way anytime you recommend anything
new in this world there are 10 million
reasons against it that get organized
but the prime minister said and and vice
president of the foundation caldera said
let's just go for this and what emerged
out of that quickly was an alliance with
the United States because President
Obama was just coming into office and
literally the first international
address I think that that Secretary of
State Hillary Clinton gave was to the
madrid conference on food and hunger
that was considering the report of the
foundation and that report called for a
new global fund for
agriculture based at the World Bank the
global agriculture and food security
program now it's not on paper it exists
it has been funded at an initial level
it already launched four programs for
for poor countries we know that about 30
countries are planning to submit plans
in October I keep telling countries
submit great plans so that we bankrupt
the fund and get it replenished as fast
as possible because we want to build the
demand and show what can be accomplished
with the proper funding now we have a
very innovative idea the one that you
spoke about at the United Nations
yesterday on innovative financing and I
know you'll touch on that and I predict
that this too with the the wisdom of my
colleague professor stiglitz and the
wisdom of the foundation there's a great
deal in here for a pathway to the
Millennium Development Goals so it's a
privilege for me to be here and without
further ado I would like all of us at
Columbia to welcome the executive vice
president of the fundación edius and the
author of these two path-breaking
reports hay-soos caldera
columbia mi amigos de personas en el
mundo y tiempo de personas mas o menos
esta por ciento de fils de los países
mess avanzados mess Desiree's chiu aoc
justo y es mira ESO stainable a ESO por
tanto demos entender cambias tengo en de
Esperanza como esta de una sola bras del
cantante 100 Tico's a ustedes vista a
los objetivos del milenio cuando dije
que algo y las cosas estan cambiando
mejor de docenas de millones de ninos
vanghele porque San Colorado las just
Isis
presidente hablo mucho y hacer caso
fetus in ENT races in durham bar knows
pegamos lo tambien con respecto a que yo
so que mas no necesitas de rossi vho
agenda de la speranza no la palabra y OS
Tigran Vitas a quien bruja está el vicio
let me first give my voice of welcome to
president cemetery oh and your
colleagues here and and and thank you
for giving our students in our community
a chance to hear your views let me just
try to very briefly give you a little
bit of introduction president zapatero
has been a major transformative figure
in Spain the remarks that Minister
caldera gave gave you a little bit of a
feeling of what has he is done he first
renovated the Spanish Socialist Party
after a period of crisis when he became
Secretary General in two thousand a very
young age in short order he then totally
changed the scene in Spain after he
became to power as prime minister in
2004 as a result of his commitment to a
truly progressive agenda in Spain Spain
is today a very different and in so many
ways a much better country for
progressives everywhere in the world we
have a certain Envy we have seen his
bonus his vision what he has
accomplished in a relatively short time
the model that he has presented for
countries all over the world today Spain
is freer and fairer more socially secure
more modern more sustainable more
diverse and more tolerant he's raised
and dealt with issues of gender equality
immigrant integration civil rights in
general and civil rights of minorities
in particular i think spain is one of
the few countries they have a minister
of equality something that i think that
many other countries need to have as
well issues of same-sex marriage have
been dealt with immigration president
zapatero has changed the very nature of
the discussion change in vocabulary
to undocumented workers as opposed to
illegal workers and I think even that
vocabulary has really signaled a
different attitude of course my much of
my interest has been watching the
economic policies which he's brought to
Spain before the crisis he had already
begun the task of transforming the
Spanish economy he realized that Spain
was excessively dependent on real estate
unlike most other governments before the
crisis he realized that when ought to
balance the budget over the cycle not in
any particular year so that before the
crisis his country had a surplus again
an object of envy of most of the rest of
the world the existence of that surplus
has meant the ex pain has been able to
address the issues posed by the crisis
that has been brought to its country
from outside much better than it
otherwise would have been and in spite
of the crisis he has been able to
continue the task of transforming the
Spanish economy what he's been doing in
terms of renewable energy in terms of
trying to create a new automobile sector
in terms of transforming in so many ways
the structure of the economy is again a
source of envy what when is seen as
those of you who visit Spain in terms of
infrastructure its companies have really
shown that green technology green
investment can be the basis of a new
future quite different from the past
this brings me now to the topic of
today's discussion and that is
development
presidential material has been a leader
in development and in Spain as
commitment to development assistance has
been truly remarkable and its commitment
to providing that much of that
assistance through the UN and through
multilateral agencies has also been
remarkable but one of the particular
aspects that I want to comment on is the
willingness to think innovatively about
a whole variety of issues including how
to finance development so presidents
about support arrow has been one of the
leaders in thinking about innovative
financial approaches to finance
including the financial transaction tax
so without any further ado let me invite
president Zapatero to the podium and to
give his address
pornostar des la universidad de colombia
es una de las instituciones academic
a--'s mess pristiq osas del mundo un
prestigio askedo grant a tous ciento
cincuenta nose por averse ido el alma
mater como no recuerda la stato de
bronze de la scala notta k das SOS
Taillow libre de muchos hombres y
mujeres que con su pensamiento / tambien
con su AC own an contribu doe a
configured el mundo y entender lo
hombres y mujeres profesor es
estudiantes que an podido destacar tanto
por su talento como por su capacidad de
compromiso haciendo un select o alenko
de Galarraga na dos por el premio nobel
Oh significant doce en su apoyo a las
casas por la denis de semana como los
estudiantes que a finales de los attenti
no do her own a quien hacer well g'day
hombre proporta star control regimen de
la Prahalis poren comprender entonces
senora's Y senores hasta que punto me
siento satisfecho yagara decido a los
organizadores desta bento por tener la
oportunidad inter- yo yo auntie ustedes
aqui en una rear decidas a la que
pertenecen personas a las que admiro
mucho y que me endren consum estas como
los profesores st glee essex wenlock a
silvio estas a pocos años el tanque
readers patada vs KU yo recuerdo de co
evoke ahora esprit cemente amigos y
amigas quisiera hablar en este encuentro
del nuevo orden economico mundial que
puede estar sue Jean lo que ha de su
here tras la crisis y del papel que and
edison venarr law sogeti voz de
desarrollo del milenio
cuyo complemento estamos hora a value
ando en a Sione's Unidas diez años
después de sua probation por todos los
líderes UND alles cuando se cumplen en
este mez dos anos de la KIBRA de los
principales bancos inversion de estados
unidos europa TOA punta k das mindy's la
economía mundial volvera a recuperar los
niveles de esta vida preciosa la crisis
economica a sissy predica crecimiento
mundial de este no se si tu en torno del
quatro por ciento algo que
afortunadamente contrast akan la
situazione que de pero la grande presion
que es el presidente de nuestra estoy
economica moderna con el que c'est comme
para por su gravitas intensa de la
crisis can so tros know so toca lo vere
tras el crack financier dame in odis
intro slinky nueve convener recorder lo
la economía mundial tardo casi una de
cada involve er a los niveles previos
actividad en el caso de el comercio esta
recuperación sarah trasera almaz por el
efecto de las grassman riyals hola
recuperación de la economía mundial es
una Cho Perez una recuperación desigual
bajo leader algo de las economy as
emergent A's yonder whole economy
gallant
and I'm solely in the case of the most
advanced economy and it's a recovery but
has not come and run with until now with
the creation of jobs and that is the
most serious problem of all we have not
yet been capable of reducing these very
high unemployment rates over 30 million
additional people without jobs
two-thirds of which in developed
countries and that is what this world
crisis has brought out but it's also a
recovery that is still subject to the
uncertainty of the financial markets and
the growth itself in the immediate
future of the United States and of
Europe this is a current situation the
better the lessons to be drawn from this
crisis and do allow me even from just
for Mama to dwelling them because it is
based on those lessons and how we learn
them and that's not exclusively a
lecture or an interchangeable technical
dissection but rather also in addition
to that a political assessment and
therefore disputable and contestable and
only then will we be able to give shaped
to the new world economic order to which
we aspire therefore
last two decades of the economy had been
bringing the crisis that broke out in
2008 as a result to great extent of a
whole set of practices in the economic
and financial world the process of
financial deregulation taking on with
not very naturally much of the markets
are acting very pernicious Lee and
instead of displacing those doubtful in
regular and of course aiming to any
functional virtue these practices mean
became structural and systemic and I'm
not going to go into these practices
consisted on I'm sure many others would
do so here much better than I would as
Professor statements for example what is
here relevant is that it generated the
illusion that we could live in the
financial system that could work on its
own
separated from reality from the genuine
reality while we were more exposed to
its fragility and success these
practices in the developed countries
together with the growth and savings in
emerging countries which in the
development of their own financial
systems launched and promoted these
bubbles and laid mines and mine field
for the
iono me and my brothers and now an
economic growth of course
in an interrupted way when we trusted in
visitors would contribute to decreasing
the inequalities around the world in the
answer this maverick our own world
conscience to pick on these problems and
this meant taking on an insufficient
pace in doing so before financial crisis
incubated in the deregulation imbalances
and real challenges that were not
tackled with enough resolve in the
context of efficient international
governance which are led us to an
in-depth transformation of the economic
world order in the outback of the crisis
has placed us before this was urgent
need as professors dignity said we've
learned that the markets can be blind
versus the imbalances that they can
generate them that they can feed them
indefinitely until one day they crop up
and cannot be avoided we've landed
markets abandoned due to delayed care
because of the lack of public Democratic
presence can represent a serious threat
to general interest said that we are
called to defend including defending the
markets itself and it's a social role
that the states must defend the
international organizations and
institutions under a logic that is quite
different
already but we might have forgotten it
they the individual logic of maximizing
sometimes uncontrolled me the the
profits perhaps what maybe Mira now is
the best dialectic relationship which is
that comes together with the reciprocal
environment that helps each other out
market Financial Supervision public
service division but individually with
individual economic freedom and interest
of the jet defending the general
interest on the other become more potent
than ever but now on a global scale
these are some lessons to be drawn from
the crisis but then which should the new
economic order be the one to be born of
this and there's consensus that the
objectives of the new economic order
should be stable growth based on solid
foundations and supported by sufficient
and effective international governments
growth that is environmentally
sustainable not only compatible with the
asteroid or comet change but that
includes this as an integral part of its
political model and growth that is
globally balance that is inclusive in
nature of regions countries and citizens
we're speaking about three elements here
that can only be conceived as
interdependent and inseparable if we do
not act
on climate change treating it is a
structural dimension of our productive
model then we wrap be able to grow in
stable and durable way and without solid
and durable growth we won't have the
necessary resources to fight climate
change if our growth continues to
marginalize significant parts of the
world population we will continue having
instability and conflicts and feel
citizens and societies contributing
effectively to the success of the
world's economy impala if growth isn't
sound and durable then it won't be
sufficiently inclusive and promote
stability and peace and in any event
it's necessary to reinforce economic
governance and international cooperation
we are already being helped by it to
come out of the crisis and it should be
the main saun of identity of the new
world economic order in this regard the
role of the g20 the corresponds of g20
should be forged and it should judge we
need financial institutions
international financial institutions
that have the necessary resources to
meet their ever-growing
in which a significant and relevant
actors feel represented it will be there
for essential to send to reform the
quotas and the executive directory of
the IMF and now I'll talk about the
Millennium Development Goals and the
role they play in this new economic
order I am aware of the fact to the
extent to which it is daring to do so
here precisely at the university of
Colombia will want to be a person's
Jeffrey Sachs who has contributed the
most to belongs to Haiti but has
contributed to the city to the creation
and achievement of the gold and he
deserves our appreciation for it well I
would like to underscore here is that
the millennium development goals in the
struggle against poverty and to be in
texas by humankind the entire younger to
minimum levels of education in health
cannot respond to among feeling of the
solidarity which of course is very
valuable and very respectable in fact
essential and thanks to the powerful
feeling of rejection that the
Intolerable a reality of extreme poverty
the
mortality if so many millions of
children / literacy and the elimination
of their dignity in the world in which
there's so much abundance in other
places and Wilton tyranny can it's
materially conceivable that we managed
to eradicate extreme poverty thanks
precisely to these feelings because
prospects to these feelings humankind
and we progress and have them so my
recently in recent years and achieving
the mdgs will be the best proof of it
but it's not enough the MDGs or not or
shouldn't be only just now there are an
ethical imperative with Amos beacons
also conceived as a structural element
of the new economic world order that
we're building the global outlook this
vision that's essential must be truly
global mobile the garden growth global
regarding international trade regarding
the financial system the energy sources
and global as well regarding the
territorial distribution of wealth which
should include in itself and it be
included in the economic world order in
addition to be projected on the
requirements of peace of instability I
believe but what this project is that
mmm
can it be understood it when the pay
attention is we are now in the United
States to the mechanisms to finance our
development aid this approach to
cooperation in the international
struggle against poverty is a
requirement of solidarity he is
complemented with result financial aid
by each country individually based on
that country's budget and possibilities
and these circumstances are always
difficult for all in times such as now
times of crisis it's true with the
generalization of the commitment of
reaching 0.7 between us the developed
nations already I've done to this this
model of volunteering national
contributions but would really make a
difference but will really mean a
quantum leap a qualitative that is
totally wings in line with our pattern
shift of inclusion from voluntary
solidary the new structural corn store
of this cool mr. of this economic orders
establishing new financing mechanisms
that are stable objective sufficient
placed at the game of the achievement of
the MDGs if we are the countries for
most powerful to the poorest on earth
now our angel global if our
responsibility there's bad surgery for
what what is happening to us in our
responses are global and that we have to
articulate and give shaped in you into
international governments we must have
an international revenue system
we'll beat attacks on financial
transactions a financial transaction tax
as a financing mechanism for the for the
mdgs because that would be most
effective as a as a system to obtain
those funds even if it isn't the
distorting amount if we put it in that
analytical framework and in my opinion
it makes out the sense in the world to
have it the Spanish government has
committed decided most decisively to
include a new innovative sources in our
fight against poverty and the MDGs is
committed to that financial transaction
tax the International tux and we're
going to do it together with other
countries we are going together with our
societies with the NGOs we are going to
be extending this requirement so there's
this minimum contribution to be paid in
each international transaction and that
may be the definitive push that we need
to eradicate extreme poverty the scourge
of extreme poverty and do I mean to tell
you that there is no goal that is more
ambitious than ever then achieving that
goal
despite knowing that it's possible and
after enduring this rough economic
crisis after seeing that the imbalances
are behind it all behind very many of
those troubles and the patterns the
citizens and countries both developed
and lesser developed are going through
right now so the time has come the time
of the truth has come first the
government's for us to take on the
Scourge that history has ever had
amongst us that is poverty and extreme
poverty now it can't be just do it isn't
it has to be the world of good
intentions to determination and resolve
and I'm not working on about eight is it
something we all need and I'm saying
that from a country that is the
developed country that has increased its
development aid to fight poverty and
extreme poverty the most we have
practically doubled our contribution
based on our GDP and our country still
preserves its objective of reaching 0.7
by 2015 the Millennium Development Goals
represent our collective mission and is
the most noble mission that humankind
has ever set for itself all world
leaders that are world leaders supported
and committed to the UN and it me five
years left to eat them and we will be
the first living generation to
eradicate extreme poverty at dying of
hunger around the world and that is the
best motivation the most stimulating
motivation that we the government's can
have together living NGOs professor
stiglitz we have to make this possible
we have to make it possible for the
governments of the world to agree on
these and em to agree on this one
international financial transaction tax
and to meet the MDGs in five years time
and short peeved and I'm also pretty
went to extreme poverty and hunger
around the world that will be the best
tribute we can pay to so many volunteer
workers to so many NGOs and all those
professors teachers who have contributed
very bravely by putting your finger on
the problems and the key problems of our
world's economy and the most important
problems are extreme poverty hunger and
quantity are therefore wish to pledge
from the government of Spain that we
will contribute most actively to that
new economic government to that new
sustainable growth that is capable of
generating jobs but jobs that are so
necessary in every country as it is
right now in Spain as well
that is part of the european union
european union that is growing ever
closer that has a growing bill of
creating that economic world order that
is to be governed and we must recall
this that the g20 which has been a key
piece in responding in a coordinated
fashion to this crisis was called a d
initiative of europe and it has gelled
to a great extent because of the
european trust and it must go through a
foundational period as a major
institution in that new world economic
order in the coming period of time and
europe is profoundly committed to
achieving that new collaboration
coordination system in the financial
economic spheres and fighting climate
change achieving the mdgs on the four
major pillars to respond to new time so
we are faced with we are now in mr.
fighting this economic crisis working
towards recovery towards changing our
productive model to which professor
stiglitz referred to to leave behind all
that investment
seeking short-term interest and
promoting fostering investment in
education in research and development
innovation development I love rich with
a commitment the commitment of
preserving social cohesion in our way
out of this crisis essentially towards
those who lost their jobs we are
therefore going through most size of
times the process has only underscored
the imperious need to create a new world
economic order but that new world
economic order can is not quite to be
born out of zone it's not going to be
out of spontaneous girls on its own
order to be fruit of nothing that mean
I've been on the go during which were
all working on and what we're trying to
do it must
recognize and be based on our
interdependence II in how all countries
depend on one another economies depend
on one another one week which depends on
the other in order to articulate and
build a true sphere of world governments
which should propose and they're putting
to place a better balance between the
markets and an supermarket supervision
that must include a structural elements
of that new world order thus the
fighting climate change to which I had
they not referred to today but that to
me it stands at the same level of
requirement and commitment is achieving
the Millennium Development Goals and of
course fighting extreme poverty and
therefore if we do want that new world
order to be born to grow mature and
govern the structural changes to balance
the risk Co these crude risks it is
absolutely essential for us to establish
additional financing mechanisms at the
service of the achievement of the MDGs
anyone who is progressive should know
intuitively but at the end of a crisis
and in fighting an economic crisis
you've got that an opportunity and not
that offers you an opportunity for
change in this case a changing the world
economic order those challenges only
have one can only have one and can only
be guided by the values of solidarity
and liberty solidarity and freedom that
require imperatively the extension of
rights and opportunities to humankind as
a whole and in times such as ours you
have to be faithful faithful to seekers
changes that external expand
opportunities that know how to use this
moment in history and that place is all
facing the reality of the changes were
going through and the policies we must
implement so I wish to thank the
university of Colombia and I would like
to tell you I want you all to know how
pleased I am to be here and then once
again reiterate my foot commitment to
the MDGs thank you so very much
well thank you very much for that
wonderful speech in which you outlined a
vision of the new economic order the
values the principles that have to
underlie that new economic order of
values of solidarity and freedom the key
elements of that new economic order
including how it has to be inclusive and
bring in the developing countries and in
doing that the need for more than money
leadership and vision moral commitment
but that money is important and if we're
going to achieve the Millennium
Development Goals there will need to be
a reliable stable source of Finance and
that is one of the areas in which you've
been making the most important
contribution we have a very limited time
we've been running over a little bit so
we have time for three or four or five
questions so I think that there should
be microphones and I'll gather the five
questions for make them brief questions
because the time is limited and then
President Salva Tara will will answer
them very briefly so is there a
microphone
oh there you go here you go stand behind
the there are two microphones there go
ahead so if you want to go line up so we
can go move very quickly yeah go ahead
precision zapatero Yong Bosch and
presidential dr o since up on butch
graces I'm getting fingered I've never
listen to a speech such as yours you've
made a wonderful speech indicating how
we can you Raticate poverty but hasn't
the g20 thought some occasion that
together with that scourge that you
referred to that there's another scourge
especially Latin America from where I
come from which is drug trafficking have
you also thought reaching an agreement
with the governance of that region to
fight against that scourge which is
costing us in which blood and caution
causing so much hardship in Latin
America okay we gather all the questions
so that the president can catch them all
together okay similar Presidente in
rockland ian chummy Oh mr. president
welcome to Colombia I want to say that
I'm a bit discouraged in seeing there's
an honor speech the only proposal that
you've made husband once again to
increase taxes to establish any new tax
especially the person who several years
ago said thus reducing taxes was a left
to idea so once afro
what doing funny realize that offenders
poverty what we have to do is fight
celeberty democracy arrives to the first
countries and not continuously bit
offending or allowing ourselves to
countries américa latina particularly
lots of America that's it really
contribute very little to democracy
because mr. president you know where the
casino better less so few not as kissing
sensually la tierra might be that's
permanent expect the societies that are
established yummier a text is the fruit
of many generations of a lot of work and
effort and that's what has to be
explored to George's notes again pensive
of 10 seconds ok hey users this morning
you said this but you're going to fight
for Spain to become in your competitive
economy could you give a small specifics
on this on how this couldn't be cheap
tank it ok i guess my questions along
the same lines as his but it was more
specifically oriented towards financing
and how you were able to raise funds
again with the push back against the
austerity measures and he just such a
little bit of map thanks thank you Brian
minister I was honoring them what you
thought the rest of the world could
learn from Spain's experience with
alternative energies thank you okay
co-presented and Fiona yes as regards
your famous cooperation comments are
there changes as productive the mobile
innovation research choice though how
does this compare to the decrease your
budget cuts in a researcher for example
unwanted postal great attend a coast as
a teacher no bus on the university I
guess you know this salary there's what
about my good salary here
I'll ask you
each sacrifice interdependent economy
Lebanese I don't know as you going into
detail and see what American countries
would celebrate nice when you said
welcome you to for example countries
such as Mary Venezuela there is no type
of legalities and mixes oh we're headed
towards poverty more than you know so
what we'll do no se I said what I make
their living a sacrifice to go to your
independence es uno de los temas de Mayo
will say well dishes world's most
cooperation in european union with latin
american particular also rather area
with the United States and of course any
dialogue between Spain and the United
States there are different programs that
exist in the European Union that's at
finance the fight against drug
trafficking the alternatives to certain
types of crops a lot American countries
and I agree in that this is a scourge
that is a terrible as the scourge of
hunger and misery in extreme poverty now
the possibility of this issue appearing
in the discussions of her g20 until now
the g20 has been concentrated on the
world economic order fiscal havens where
progress has been achieved in these past
few months no this beneficial even
question it was a statement almost as
regards financial transactions
for me person of this 2222 attacks on
financial transactions practically it
would be a very limited tax for every
financial transaction but the result of
the application of attacks can be
spectacular but of course we need a rule
of law the democracies to consolidate
progress in these countries we fully
agree with that the Spaniards node up
very well fortunately we've already
lived through 30 years of democracy
written the fighting to consolidate
ourselves as a solid country democratic
country stable country but it's a
presence of the government I do have a
series of opinions the vaccinations that
are financed by Spanish operation
through Spanish taxes are allowing us to
save a lot of lives in South Saharan
Africa these schools that are financed
by Spanish cooperation with taxes from
Spaniards are saving enough are allowing
children in sub-saharan Africa to go
through school to have studies and Java
radically different future than they
would have had otherwise and while we
consolidate democracy while we fight
because it's just as important when we
fight for there to be adequate
institutions this is essential if you
want children not to die if you want
them to be able to educate themselves we
need to finance develop even fade inward
to finance it not only do states have to
have a good wolf
it's important we need the Solidarity of
citizens which is important too but why
not we could also establish a mechanism
to stabled mechanism a solid mechanism a
lasting mechanism where we could tax
financial transactions in order to
contribute with a volume of financial
transactions that we have nowadays in
this historical moment thanks to the
globalization why not use that to fight
against extreme poverty and hunger I
think it's fair and that nothing has to
do with an option that could be opposed
to the need of democracy and the rule of
law being implemented in these countries
which is what really consolidates the
situation in these countries that allows
for welfare and stimuli and full
participation of the citizens but if we
don't have funds money we cannot put an
end to extreme poverty and just funding
through cooperation aid that is not
sufficient so I think it's something
that has to be done and in this case as
in almost every case whether we use
taxes or not he's not necessary linked
to any ideology it's just an instrument
I see it as a simple instrument to
achieve an end the goal perhaps
increasing taxes at a given time might
be a useful option progressive option
but also lowering taxes as well so I do
not have any dogmatic approached is if
one phil has taught us the lessons that
a cover have students learn like Christ
such this one has shed us that's a
fundamentalist extremist our positions
just lead to failure and that a
government with a progressive mentality
can as we have done lower taxes certain
types of taxes
with a certain goal with certain aim or
we can establish higher rates tax rates
depending on the circumstances and I
really like to send a question and on
top of that I saw that you received a
lot of support on conditions working
conditions yes Louise issues always get
an applause but i have to say quite
clearly that the government that i
preside since 2004 has multiplied
threefold public's expenses in research
development and innovation we purchased
it threefold this is the period was the
biggest increase in research and
development there's no comparison boss
bro it's allowed us to reach one point
three seven percent of expenditure and
it's the period in which more rights and
improvements have been given to people
in a world of research when we arrived
in the government as regards social
security and different social benefits
and rights when we took over government
they were in calling situation that the
situation is not the best still fine but
the fears I've given say it all and with
the economic crisis the amounts that
have been less affected in the general
budget in 2009 as in 2010 as will also
be the case in 2011 is everything that
has to do with researcher development
and innovation in education there's
still a lot to do in investments in this
year yes but in the past six years we've
progressed more than many previous
period and that's the truth of the
matter and the proof is that nowadays
where the north world power in
scientific production
unfortunately we are already reaching
the threshold that corresponds to us as
regards returns from the European
Union's thermic research former program
and the private sector has to involve
itself much more and also invest in
research and development renewables
Spain though occupies a certain
leadership position in renewables we
have the strongest companies in the
world as regards the solar energy wind
energy as well and that is not by pure
chance it's due to a policy that we've
clearly bet for renewable energies you
renewable energies are in responsible
option in the fight against climate
change they bring innovation they bring
technological capacity and they generate
stable employment and qualified
employment therefore we will continue to
bet on this option Latin America some
countries have been mentioned Venezuela
fight against poverty extension in
consolidation of democracy as I
mentioned before are absolutely
indispensable for there to be growth
well-being and I have to say that in
spite of the difficulties or the
specific circumstances that there might
be in one given country latin america as
a whole right now has two
characteristics
that should make us a look at Latin
America with a positive view it's
resistant quite well this economic
crisis it's the time is the best
resisted in economic crisis and with
very few exceptions that we've seen
recently in Latin America well they're
going through a period democratic
government here's house interruptions
which is the most extensive period that
they've had in recent history Spain
because of its a special links with
Latin America has always worked for
institutional consolidation for the
improvement of democracies in all Latin
American countries we try to improve the
political dialogue within each Latin
American country and we support economic
consolidation and social development in
this very young call centers which has a
population of 500 million people and has
appt enormous potential and furthermore
where the United States should establish
a more intense dialogue professor
Stevens I've tried to answer all the
questions that were made going into a
big detail I hope I've left nothing
unanswered and I'd like to thank you for
your questions and I've tried to explain
clearly the objectives are facts the
real facts and of course I'm very
satisfied of having a established all of
these coincidence that we've established
as regards the achievement of the
Millennium Development Goals spain i
think has fulfilled with its commitments
will development aid thanks to the
Solidarity of spanish citizens and this
means that we've saved flight when we've
increased hope and if the world adopts
the international financial transaction
tax
this will mean more lives more education
more opportunities and more health and
that is what we want and that's why
we're here thank you very much